auch mein haus ist es wunderschön ich
hab noch nie so ein schönes horst sind
noch nie ich schaue mir gleich mal an da
machen wir so ein kind kennt zu mtv
cribs ja aber ich würde eine richtige
villa machen
das mache ich jetzt mal bei deinem
ausgleich da warte ich bis jetzt stufen
kräfte schönes dach hab aber dass so
viel luxus muss jetzt nicht sein also
kurz interessenten schrieb kraft hast du
noch einen server auf genannten schon
von der fähigkeit spiele bett lag ich
bin der abba bevor ich denke es ist auch
mal witzig wenn man auf den premium
server ist nicht wahrscheinlich weil du
in deinem betten sport besucher sogar
dein haus ein kleines rädchen hatte ich
will den zombie schlagen dann kriegt
experience aus holz das versteigerte
ersteigern natürlich den wert
dahinten rennt schon wieder so ein erbe
schneller ich bin ganz tief in der höhle
gefallen
ich lebe ich lebe noch knapp viereinhalb
viereinhalb herzen
sie kann ich mich nicht erinnern dass
ich höre schon eine spinne schon wieder
ich höre einen spanischen wieder eine
spinne auch sehr klug gespielt haus mtv
cribs hey zeigen sie uns noch mal heraus
hauptsache hat einiges daraus und und
eine kiste drin
erwartet wird jetzt anscheinend
verbinden wird vielleicht auch eine
schöne kiste okay ach so denn die schöne
kiste ein neues objekte minecraft
hinzugefügt von vize biest schöne kiste
die stifter 20 schön dass weihnachten
allem christen so geschenkt
eine schöne idee ja mal was neues ich
laufe einfach jede höhle suchen
das sind schon das letzte große
geheimnis zu meinem haus ein ruhiger
bild
das hat jetzt nicht laut gesagt oder oma
nicht mit einer höhle hier sobald dies
marble zeugs jetzt nicht schlucht wissen
sogar zurück machen kann
mit diesem mar buildings machen kann und
allgemeine den ganzen sachen wie ich
hier findet wie zum beispiel retten oder
betrugs juroren oder gewinnsicherung
oder leipzig wo es ist alles gleich in
verschiedenen farben
die leute haben uns auch geschrieben die
sonst so schnell wie möglich zum bohrer
machen dann verdoppeln wir unser ertrag
doppeln borat wahrscheinlich macht euch
borat den hamburger hänger ja wobei ich
mich jetzt nicht bauen jetzt erstmal
dahin rechnet wegen solcher noch machen
eine tür weil ein gutes haus ist nur so
gut wie seine tür jagt man definitiv ja
soweit ich weiß jetzt richtig gewesen
die würde glaube ich leider erst mal ein
paar sachen ein haus baue ich dann
irgendwann so demnächst post also mein
haus ist fertig es ist wunderlich bitte
nicht etwas fertig es wundert es nicht
fertig fehlt noch eine sache
eine sache fehlt und dann kannst du
gucken kommen nur dann kann ich das auch
machen habe ich auch schon ne menge gut
so dann warten wir eben bisher als es
fertig ist dann mache ich mir direkt
eine neue spitze und ein neues schwert
reisen
am besten wird schwer hast du das würde
vor dem hause kommt ein schild dran oder
wie ich bin
guck mal ganz normal erwartet
ich komme ich möchte mich auf internet
wie youtube bald die mtv cribs ok bilder
sind sie das ja der winter scheint herr
krebs ja eher heufer-umlauf oder tasche
gesteckt
lauf piste heufer-umlauf umlauf auch bei
ihnen angekommen meinen kindern auch den
heufer-umlauf defekt
ach herr klaas heufer-umlauf aber ich
finde das eigentlich hat einen sehr
coolen humor wir dann immer so nahmen
die kamera wenn yoko dann sind die
beiden sowieso eher die beiden in einem
team das passt einfach
die machen jetzt irgendwie zdfneo auf
youtube die haben so einen youtube kanal
zdfneo und dann machen die auch videos
ich hab ihn über die die wenn ich du
wäre und aushalten das fand ich ja sehr
geil von den das habe ich mir mal
angeguckt das wird aber immer von
anderen usern hochglanz wunderschöne
fahrt von gespielt
okay okay meine freunde sind bei mtv
cribs astrologe spielt erhält oder
umgestellt sind die daten ich bin
endlich zu hause aber das ist auch der
einzige und mein haus betreten darf ok
ok hallo jetzt ein paar kisten okay hier
ist nichts besonderes drin im bett
das mtv cribs und das ist schön
es ist mtv cribs der kohle vergessen ich
wollte mir noch mehr kohle mit der ohne
kohle kohle kohle was soll ich dass du
deine krone
nein hier aber die krone die die habe
ich die kraft aber das kommt noch
und dann dann dominiere ich dich hier
spitz ich bin jetzt mit voller elan in
die höhe mit voller elan mit nidda mit
mitleid mit voller elan
die stores sales um 44 agnes vielleicht
übertrieben aber flächen ist und ich
habe wieder colo colo colo colo
wir waren jetzt 1 1 0 1 gar keine themen
ausgesteuerte wir quatschen können aber
ich denke das werden wir einfach die
nächsten folgen machen wir jetzt
wirklich manchmal kann auch ohne themen
viel quatschen finde die haben auch über
werbung images war immer nachher stimmt
ist aufgefallen
wir haben uns eben darüber unterhalten
das will doch gar nicht benutzen und
tiefen das ach so was ich gerade auch
feststelle wir haben wahrscheinlich die
mod drin die ich auch so in meinem lost
let's play verwenden werde
und zwar das werden eine spitzhacke
kaputt ist dass ich dann sofort die
nächste einheit dass man direkt abholen
kann
dass man danach erst komisch und
sortieren muss wenn die sache leer ist
oder das gleiche glaube ich auf der erde
wenn du nur noch einen er da hast du
hast in deinem inventar noch einen stack
und dann ist der eine weg dann gibt
jetzt muss sich das automatisch dahin
sage ich mal ist sehr sehr geil
okay ich bin da sehr sehr dunklen
schluchten ganzen sachen ab wofür ich
vorhin diese eisen links brauchte und
wie sieht es wirklich aus wenn so best
sie mich anschauen das erz ja die diese
ärzte dieses rote und wieso seine blauen
augen
ich brauche mir fackeln fällt mir drauf
aber ich habe ja zum glück sticks und
kohle ist immer noch das altbekannte
weise dafür schon zu hause weil er weiß
einfach wo es heute also da weiß man was
man damit anfangen kann
ja ich will noch überfordert mit der
vielfalt dieser mich natürlich und
natürlich da da ein leben wäre versuchen
uns da ein zu leben wird natürlich seine
zeit dauern deswegen wird es auch länger
dauern das let's play und nicht nach
irgendwie jetzt morgen abgebrochen sein
übermorgen übernommen zwei dumme
gedanken und so ein also lässt wer
kommentare er schreibt und jetzt zu
konstruktiver diese kommentare sind und
nicht leute sind voll von target geklaut
dann wird sich da auf jeden fall was
machen lassen dass sie dann auch fast
anspruchsvolleres bauen werden als nur
ein scheiß mtv cribs aus was natürlich
wunderschön aus ich glaube ich habe die
am 8
dass man von dem partner das texture
pack verändert man macht einfach eisen
zu diamanten und dann freute sich total
dass ich mal bei dehner machen so
einfach so aber weil ich immer viel zu
faul zu vor allem weil auch sein lena
packard und das dann immer sein eigenes
benutzt aber ist auf jeden fall glaube
ich mal ganz ein ganz cooler streich was
hältst du davon
ich finde das eine schöne idee aber
jetzt hast du schon verraten das heißt
mit mir ganz lustig machen nee ich
machte sony mit ihren gut spielt auch
viel zu brav um getrotzt
habt ihr schon längst gerollt ich will
euch habt ihr eigentlich und eisen
daraus können wir das auf einmal weg und
wenn dem 15
ja ich weiß dass alle durch vor dem papa
ich hab dann ins mich gleich moment
drauf gedrückt ach das ist silver oder
es gibt also einen unterschied zwischen
eisen und silber und dies alles ist klar
dass es nun dass zwischen uns läufer
gibt die aber im normalen michael
schellberg wilbär also seit einigen
jahren als damals wirklich auch immer
silber genannt habe damals war eine ganz
coole zeit da wo minecraft halt noch
nicht so ausgeweitet
obwohl ich eigentlich jetzt muss ich
sagen mittlerweile finde es echt immer
geiler dass man sachen entscheiden kann
weil ich mich halt damit befasst haben
und welche dann herausgefunden habe
schon hat schon seine sinne und so das
ist alles cool und fresh weil damals das
heißt damals also vor zwei drei monaten
war ich natürlich toller befruchten da
sehr sehr gefällt das adjektiv nicht
anders gut gebrauchen wollte ich weiß
noch gar nicht von kritik stehende preis
wirklich verstehen und preisvergleiche
da war ich so drauf von wegen ja das ist
ja total oh ich hab gehört dass total
scheiße minecraft den wochen laufzeit
über das war ich 20 bin fast weggeflogen
reich heißt du drauf minecraft geht in
die komplett falsche richtung mit den
ganzen updates und man steigt dann
nachher zeit gar nicht mehr durch und
jetzt mittlerweile habe ich aber
herausgefunden wie ihn einige dinge
funktionieren und da macht muss ich
sagen macht echt spaß wieder das mit den
updates ihren so muss ich zugeben ja
ganz auf ein ganz normales ohne motto
let's play war nicht so lustig weil man
kennt halt vieles einfach schon aus
videos und zu diesem tag und weil es
auch einfach mal ausprobiert und so aber
das hier ist wieder mal was ganz also
ist wie ein neues spiel weil ich kenne
die ganze sache nicht mehr muss alles
neu lernen und das was ich immer am
besten finden spiele zum beispiel die
phase wollen selber noch so knop ist
also das ist eigentlich das geist an
spielen bei meiner sachen raus finden
kann sagt ich mir dann op ist nachher
zeit spielt es dann langweilig ich weiß
nicht warum aber also ich kann mir das
so eine geschichte erzählen
wenn sie den rahmen findet also ich hab
früher erzählt umfangreich ich bin total
spannend am sachen abbauen